my next guest is a very funny comedian
from the bay area
she's been featured in the book we had a
little real estate problem
the unheralded story of the native
americans in comedy
please welcome the very funny jackie
khali
that's a great name thank you appreciate
it yeah hi how are you doing
this is my first time meeting you you've
seemed like an early adapter to
zoom comedy right away you were on the
zoom comedy train you adjusted right
away
oh yeah totally invested in a real
microphone
got a little ring light started
producing shows back in april so it'll
be a year anniversary which is
who knew who knew i don't think i would
do it if you would have told me a year
ago that it was gonna be this long
that no i'll i'll end it i'm gonna end
this long
i had no idea and i remember just it was
my birthday was the end of march last
year and i thought okay
i'm jealous of everyone who has a summer
birthday because we're gonna be on the
other end of this
oh yeah i just was naive and i'm happy
that i didn't know a thing
that we'd be doing zoom comedy for a
year people would have lost it
if if we would have told them it's a
year yeah i was like maybe
may could you imagine no it was terrible
we had a live show we were producing
and we i think it was like the a little
bit after like maybe it was the third
week of march
and we thought we probably people are
starting to cancel shows but people are
like
who cares it's not a big deal it's a
other country thing
and uh we ended up postponing it and
saying we'll be back in april
and uh yeah that was the last post
so here we are last show i did i was on
stage in pittsburgh
and it didn't go that well because it
was like part of like people were
everything was shutting down that day
and the whole room smelled like bleach
and i walked up the stage and i was like
you know what
there's always next show oh and then
there wasn't
there was no show for an entire year
and now it's today do you feel like you
got it in was it a fun set
was it no it didn't go it wasn't like i
bombed but it wasn't like a knock out of
the park because it was the day
it was like right after the nba had shut
down uh you do
morning radio to promote your show and
the morning radio show host tested
positive
for govid he didn't cancel and the staff
was worried that just like the
bleach in the air was very eerie not the
best
element for comedy no it didn't go great
and i was like
there's always tomorrow i'm booked on my
first outdoor show uh
next month exciting i was reached out to
six months ago and someone said hey i
want to get you on this show
here are the options and i was like
let's do 2021 hopefully things will be
better by then
yeah so she hit me up and said hey are
we still on for next month and i was
like oh my god that was six months ago
so we'll see i'm i don't i'm just
prepared to just
talk as i like to write on stage and so
i'm just excited for that opportunity
like i've done
material and stuff on zoom shows but i
actually do crowd work on zoom oh
hey you got a cool background dude you
know yeah so
i'm just excited to play with people and
and hopefully they respond
i don't know what they do out there
anymore hard work has also gotten a
little dicey i've done zoom crowd work
and i'm like wha
look at this guy's got so much stuff in
his van are you living in that van he
was like yeah
i lost
i was here to laugh about it thanks for
the reminder i was like
hold on let's put his venmo in the chat
just trying to bail
immediately if you want to send him a
few bucks unless that's pandering i'm
sorry
yeah it is you don't know what people
are going through so there's no more
like look at this guy's dumb shirt
because this is the last shirt that my
father wore before he went to the
hospital he's like
jesus oh yeah and then that's the thing
too you're going to have
comics on your show who've lost people
who want to work it out
in your show and it's fresh and new the
loss
you know and so that's also a whole new
territory that i don't think any of us
had experienced but
it's it's happened seen it on a couple
of shows
uh so then you're trying to go on the
dating apps then oh my god i did
and it was a [ __ ] show yeah i i thought
okay i want to connect let's see
and i did the hinge and i had been doing
tinder but tinder's like just kind of
it's just a wasteland not that hinge is
much better it's the same dude here's
the thing it's the same dudes
on hinge and tinder it's just their
hinge profile has pictures of their
nieces and nephew to let them know that
they're serious like i don't know
it's the same dude like i literally
would see the same guys and go oh okay
um it was weird i i did dates
and they look like this basically you're
on like a zoom calling
yes that's an outdoor patio in masks
i did a couple of outdoor social
distance dates with one dude but like
i got onto the apps and was just trying
to like first
gauge i was just trying to gauge like
all right are you worth
me potentially exposing myself like let
me do an initial interview
and see if you're not a murderer and
then like maybe you've got a personality
you know but uh
yeah there were a couple of like really
bad calls where i was like okay one dude
was watching
um football he was like oh the raiders
are playing so anyways
and just kept looking like off the
screen and i was like um i think you're
watching a game
like maybe we don't need to do this no
it's cool it's fine it's fine it's fine
so anyway i'll hold on a second
and i was just like what the [ __ ] what's
here you clearly have nothing later you
have nothing to do
like can you i don't know it was just
stevie yeah is the thing
yeah that's uh that's brutal i mean it
was brutal it sounds romantic it sounds
like i know we're gonna see terrible
romantic comedies about like
you know lockdown at first sight or
whatever but
it is something about just being a human
that there is
communication that happens that is
non-verbal
that is right around someone feeling it
and it's very hard
to build a connection that way because
someone could just be nervous
because they're looking at like i never
i'm out of date and have to look at my
own face the entire
time exactly i did like have one video
call with a guy
that i thought was cool we had we had
been communicating through text for a
while and finally we made time for a
call
and then he answers the phone and is
like whispering and i was like what
and i was like are you on a plane he's
like uh i'm on a bus this fool was on a
greyhound and i was like why
we set a time and place for this to
happen and then he basically was like i
live in reno nevada
and i was like you said san francisco it
was just like i was like okay
every every was out
yeah he's going every weirdo third
family
exactly what's the worst line you've
gotten like the worst like
opening line because they try to find
that that like i want to catch your
attention but it can sound
insane moses there's so many awful
things i think the one thing that caught
me the most off guard
was one guy who was like hold on a
second that's my daughter and i was like
uh
and he had wait as an unproven line well
we had had
our first call together and he was like
hang on a second i have to
switch over to my daughter and there was
no indication this person had kids
and then during the first minute and a
half discovered he had
multiple kids and i was like okay this
man
probably didn't put any truth on this
profile so i should probably go
now um but yeah that there's just
terrible
it's just bad i i i hate i wish i could
be more positive
it just doesn't work yeah it doesn't
work which means after this is gonna be
uh oh god festival i'm sex
it's gonna be rabbits so many people
doing sex on each other all this pen
weird sex too i'm so excited moses i was
like all right give me that [ __ ]
vaccine
right right here right here okay no i
i'm it's
it's pent up man and it's funny because
it's spring and i'm telling you we're
animals at the end of the day and if
there's anything that we've become close
with it's our animalistic primalistic
nature
like during the last year survival all
these things
and so i feel like oh spring's happening
uh oh
i can just i can feel it in the air and
i am excited i have a group of friends
we're all gonna go out and just
be seen we're gonna wear masks and be
responsible human beings because
that's how we've gotten it this far but
uh yeah
so excited for spring and summer yeah
every joke has to start with like i'm
single i'm single so i've been thinking
about darfur like you have to start it
doesn't matter what the topic
is i hate to be that person now i was
like i never wanted to be this comic
and i'm letting people know hey yeah i'm
excited to just meet people because you
know comics like
we feel vibes we feel energy we have
that sensitivity
and you can't accomplish that over a
video chat or like a facetime or a zoom
so i'm just excited to like meet people
and just like
see what they're about and i don't know
we'll see it's going to be fun dating
this year i'm excited
guys she's she's up she's looking
guys gals it's just anyone backpack gals
so jackie when's this outdoor show when
can people uh
see you if someone's in the bay area
yeah it's actually half moon bay of all
places uh but that's where they're do
they've been doing outdoor shows out
there for a while